bitte
wie geht die kinder geht es um das man
versucht an meiner mappe zu arbeiten
kann mich nicht kunstrasenplatz einzeln
können komplette setz dich dieser seite
führte streifenwägen selbst sehr wohl wo
maschinen roma schiefer ist nicht daran
zu gewöhnen dass chemische keine 1000
15.000 euro kommst du bitte mal hier
stimmt etwas nicht wir hatten bei dem
charity event es lukas betreut hat eine
rechnung für zwei technik dienstleister
edelweiß technik und einmal
veranstaltungstechnik müller zum 2 kein
augen frank lukas aber macht das nach
dem termin
ich freue mich so für euch
gestern abend ich war so geschockt wie
es doch dass du träumst
du bist ja immer noch hier
ich kann locker vielleicht bei ihrer
arbeit stellen natürlich kannst du du
musst mit ihr sprechen
es hat doch keinen sinn
aber du liebst sie doch warum hast du
eigentlich damals nicht weiter und
verdaut gekämpft aber uns nicht
auseinander gebracht hätte dann wäre ich
jetzt verheiratet und schwanger
das ist keine antwort auf meine frage
kümmere dich um deine freunde
wer jemals die ganze zeit besetzt denn
es ruhig kleine ruf bestimmt zurück je
besser zu ihm jetzt machst du erst mal
mit ach du musst schließlich war essen
bei den ganzen stress schätzelein bist
du verrückt vielleicht darf man doch in
ihrem zustand überhaupt nicht essen wenn
das hackfleisch gut durchgebraten ist
sind toxoplasmose und listeriose
ausgeschlossen
könntet ihr bitte keine sicher richtig
hallo
wir haben schon mal angefangen
mark hat neuigkeiten aus berlin ich habe
euren planen das gesamtkonzept von
brügmann media eingearbeitet und dem
ministerium gemeldet
wir haben dazu eine telefonkonferenz
gemacht und die haben sich erstaunlich
schnell gemeldet und sicherlich an allen
ecken und enden gekürzt es gibt bei
diesem thema nicht nur um geld
nicht nur aber auch joojoo das
ministerium ist von der originalität
eure ideen so begeistert dass ich euch
schon die zusage für die großen bühnen
events geben kann
sie haben weitere gelder bewilligt das
nicht aber wir verteilen das budget im
tempo nun sagt schon mag
wie hoch ist denn unser budget wir reden
über 500.000 euro